now let's get started I'd like to
introduce my esteemed colleague
professor Tom cosmic professor Cott
cosmic is a Fenwick and West consulting
faculty member with the Stanford
Technology Ventures program at the
School of Engineering he's an
international advisor for the National
University of Singapore entrepreneurship
Center he also taught marketing at
Harvard Business School from 1985 to
1989 and launched their entrepreneurial
marketing course which he taught from
1995 to 97 Tom helps leaders and teams
and startups global companies and other
organizations apply best of class tools
to overcome real-world challenges he has
served as a leadership coach and adviser
to hundreds of entrepreneurial leaders
and teams from 1980 to the present in
companies like Apple China Mobile HP IBM
and Ernst & Young you're in good hands
with Tom today but I'd like to now turn
it over to Professor cosmic who will
take us through our session today Thank
You Carissa and welcome everybody I'm
really glad you're here the thing that
we're going to do today is to give you a
glimpse at two of the tools that we will
be using in the build winning
stakeholder relationships of course so
that you'll have a concrete takeaway
that you can use at the end of the
session but you also get a preview of
one of the things that we'll be doing
and of course when we come so how to
earn the trust of a stakeholder here's
what we're going to cover you can read
faster than I can talk so if you'll just
look quickly at those five major bullets
and know that the key thing is about
stakeholder excuse me trust the trust
spider and start stop keep and we'll get
right into it
the objective of the session is to
introduce a trust fighter as a tool that
you can use to establish trust and
diagnose problems there are roading
trust and most project managers that I
know are always thinking about how to
build trust not only for themselves but
for their teammates
with the clients and the stakeholders
that they are serving and so the trust
part is a tool that you can use there
we're also going to introduce a second
tool that we call start/stop keep which
is a way that you can find out if
there's something a roading trust and
then close the trust gap by creating
very specific plans to change behavior
and we'll talk about that toward the end
so first let's think about the
stakeholders at this point as you look
at the screen and you see that you're in
the center is the project manager
surrounded by stakeholders of all types
ranging from your own project team to
your manager the middle and upper
management to a community that may have
an interest in the project that you're
doing in that community could be inside
your company or could be outside the
organization there may be government
entities involved there may be some sort
of public interest group that is either
very much in favor very much against the
project that you're engaged in if you're
in a public publicly traded company
you've got shareholders and if you're
going to start up you've got investors
and if you're in a nonprofit institution
you've got the people who donate and are
really word to make sure that you make
good use of their funds as well and then
on the supplier side you may have
consultants working with you you may
have suppliers that provide you physical
components if you're building a product
or they may provide you technology that
allows you to run your project think of
any person who's the customer or the
client for the product or services
you're offering as a client or the owner
of the product or service there may be
other people are not on your team and
there may be what we would call end
users and the difference between a
client and an end user would be the
client actually pays you for the project
and finances it and then users would be
anybody who's actually benefiting from
what the projects about
so think about what stakeholders you're
most concerned about now that are on
this diagram and if you have another
stakeholder that's not there I'd love to
hear about it as we go and go into Q&A
and you could certainly add that to the
to the slide here's a trust binder I
first developed this in the late 80s
early 90s with a large systems
integrator and we were training the
project team managers that were leading
very complex projects and they ran into
this problem of having multiple
constituents lots of people that they
had to please and they wanted to figure
out a better way to establish trust and
then maintain it through the course of
the project and beyond and we did a
literature review and found the the
words that are on the trust spidered as
each of the at each of the spider legs
as well as integrity which is in the
center are the qualities of leaders that
a literature search and talking with a
lot of people who are involved with
projects said were important qualities
of someone who is going to work with
someone especially someone who's going
to lead you'll notice that integrity is
in the center and it's there because
every source that we looked at and
consulted said that honesty or integrity
was foremost and if you didn't have that
nothing else really mattered so we put
that really at the heart of the spider
and we put the other qualities around
the side now if you're interested in
what we mean by any of these words that
are around the the spiders such as
chemistry or sense of humor or
confidence we have a bunch of
definitions of the behaviors that would
define that quality in the appendix
we're not going to go through them today
but you'll have them in the appendix
after the session is done okay because
so let's see how do we use this dress
spider the first thing that you would do
is look at the qualities and ask
yourself what are the five qualities
that are most critical
earn my trust as a project leader for a
program manager and so just take a
minute and start thinking about that
because we're actually going to ask you
to do that later on in the time that we
have together all right so which ones
are important to you and then you would
tell your stakeholder that you'd like to
meet with them and that you have a tool
that you'd like to show them and share
with them to understand how you all can
work together in you can earn that
stakeholders trust at that point you
show the stakeholder the tool and you
talk to him or her about it a little bit
and you don't show them your qualities
what I've got here is me having done the
exercise and you can see that my top
five our integrity grace under pressure
chemistry perspective and cooperation
commitment having done lots of projects
and worked for longer than I care to
mention these are the things that are
actually most important even reliability
which is terribly important to most
people I can that would probably be my
sixth but these are the things are
actually more important than that which
is different from what most people would
say but imagine you've done this and
you've marked your top five you then
come to your stake holder and when he or
she reveals the top five you realize
what's and we have a typo on the slide
there should actually be a red bar by
communication as well I apologize for
that so imagine that you've got your
stakeholders saying communication
confidence fairness reliability and
integrity those are her top five in fact
this is a real exercise that I did with
a very important stakeholder when we saw
the results we both took a very deep
breath and went oh we only agree on one
thing
integrity now you may ask yourself why
would we ever go to a stakeholder and
get ourselves in this sort of trouble
why would we do it and hear the reasons
the first is that different people do
have different priorities from what it
takes to earn their trust and you're
never going to learn about those
priorities unless you ask so the tool
gives a fairly straightforward way
for your stakeholder to reveal something
that otherwise would be very hard to get
at if you don't communicate priorities
at the beginning of the project and you
don't understand what your sake holder
really wants and values there's likely
to be conflict there's likely to be
you'll never establish trust or it may
erode as you go through the project
which guarantees that the project will
have troubles with that stakeholder if
you could discover the priorities early
you can also ask the stakeholder in that
meeting how can we best practice that
quality for example if communication is
really important how do you like to be
communicated with so my team and I can
learn about that and you can also say
what are example examples of the things
that would be a violation of that
quality what has someone done in the
past that has eroded trust with you that
it's just written you crazy
and as I've used this tool and seeing
others use it over the years
stakeholders are very happy to tell you
what they want how they want it and to
bring up examples of things never to do
so it can be a very rich discussion make
sure that you've got somebody ready to
take notes and then finally if you're
alone with the stakeholder which is
often the case you can communicate with
stakeholders permission his or her
priorities to the rest of your project
team so everybody is on the same page so
imagine that for every stakeholder your
entire team knows that different people
need to be treated differently in order
to earn their trust the ability to
actually build trust goes way up
everybody on the project now we're going
to do this for real
we'd like everybody to identify the five
qualities that are most critical to earn
your trust and what you do do it right
now by going to sobota ng that Carissa
is going to this is going to do for you
Christa can you take take control yeah
give me just one minute here okay
so you don't know Karissa's I hope you
didn't see Karissa's values yet the
whole idea here is for you to do your
own without being influenced by hers
hopefully you weren't influenced by mine
or by stakeholders but at any rate let's
see where you go no way you can't you
know what I grew this I have business
everybody I am so sorry I'm so sorry
as long as you've done so Tom what will
view here is I'm just going to clear the
results if everyone can just for one
moment and I'm going to clear the
results and please don't respond yet so
we're going to jump back to the slide we
were on before and all that Tom continue
okay this is me getting so excited
because actually you wouldn't know what
what the stakeholder was before you got
into to see him or her but I'm hoping
that you have identified their qualities
okay so assuming you've done that
imagine that Carissa is your stakeholder
very important to client multi-million
dollar project and you walk in and she
fills out the form and presents it to
you and you see aha
integrity communication confidence
cooperation commitment in it
entrepreneurship now before we go any
farther vote now and what we want to do
is see and Krista will turn this back
over to you
some of you may be a perfect match some
of you may only have hit four out of
five or three or two or one or none and
there's no right answer here but what we
want to do is get a distribution from
you as to what some of those qualities
are yes so now please feel free to vote
and see how similar you are with me we'd
like to we'll share these results with
you in a minute to see how close we are
seven
okay so I think we're going to wait two
more seconds for everyone to see and
then about ten more seconds to before we
close the polls and now we're going to
close the polls and share the results
with you okay so now now the results are
showing and I'm going to turn it back to
Tom okay
No how do I get to my screen there we go
so what's happening um let me let me
focus a little bit on this slide here as
you can see only 8% of you had a perfect
match and 39% 21% were and 3% were three
two or one out of five which is not
unexpected and what the key thing I want
you to take away from this is it's
highly likely that you and your
stakeholder are going to have different
points of view and that's good news if
it happens because you can quickly learn
more about what that stakeholder means
when he or she is talking about the
qualities and you can figure out a
better way to earn his or her trust okay
now the next thing we're going to do is
think about this tool after you've
already gotten your initial conversation
with the stakeholder let's imagine it's
three months later and you want to find
out how you've been doing you've got a
major project milestone so you bring
back the spider and you with the spider
in front of you you guys a stakeholder
are there any issues that have to do
with integrity if there's anything that
you think I'm doing that makes you
question whether I'm being honest or
whatever anybody on my project team
please tell me because we really want to
deal with that and should there be
something focus on that and it may be
that you don't do anything but that
because integrity issues wrestle
critical to a project assuming that the
stakeholder says no no no integrity
issues you ask this stakeholder to draw
lines on the spider connecting the dots
on the spider scale that gives an
assessment of his or her performance
we're going to show you an example of
that in just a minute but imagine that
they're basically saying okay I think
you're a three out of five on
communication and I think you're a two
out of five on entrepreneurship they
would connect those dots with a middle
line and you by the way have filled out
your own self-assessment separately
before going into the meeting okay
preferably with a different color ink or
something once again you compare notes
and we're going to show you the example
in just a moment and what you want to do
knowing is there will be gaps where you
think you're doing better than your
stakeholder does that's what we call a
trust gap focus on one or two of them
and figure out a way to change the
situation so that you can rebuild trust
and and close the trust gap and we're
going to use the start-stop keep as a
tool to show you how to do that exact
thing so let's give an example here it's
Tom and his stake holder once again and
it turns out as I'm preparing for the
meeting I'm saying oh I'm sorry that's a
stakeholder assessment so the stake
holder is not very happy with
communication that's not very good and
not very happy with reliability that's
not very good so those are probably two
we really have to look at and it turns
out that I had a much better feeling
about how he was doing this stakeholder
good so you can see that time so what
okay here we have the two together right
so the the stakeholders are here in the
dotted lines and I'm in the dark solid
line I think I'm doing pretty darn well
on communication and
is really not happy with that there's a
smaller gap on real-life reliability but
I would certainly want to close that gap
as well because that's saying a 2 out of
5 which signals a serious problem we
it's not that we ignore competence and
fairness but to get focused
let's take communication as an example
so I turn to the stakeholders say my
gosh I had no idea that communication
was such a problem tell me more about
what I've been doing that has caused you
concern and here let's use a tool to
help us figure out what I need to do
differently actually we do yes so at
this point you let the the stakeholder
just tell you a lot of the things you've
been doing that may have been driving
him or her crazy an example would be
you're late for meetings another is I
don't get enough information in between
meetings to know how the project is
going sometimes do you communicate with
somebody on my team without letting me
know and I really don't like to be to
find out about that without without
having been told in advance I don't mind
you talking to other people on my team
but police you see me all sorts of
things that may be related to
communication that are things that you
can change so imagine you've made your
list and you say to the stakeholder what
are some specific things that I can do
in the next 30 days start doing that I'm
not doing now stop doing things that are
driving you crazy or keep doing if
there's anything that I've been doing
with respect to communications that has
been good please tell me about that so
that I don't throw the baby out with the
bathwater and I'd love to know also the
the impact on you of the problems of
communication so in the Y box what I'm
going to do is take down the things that
you tell me about why it's important
that we start or stop or fatigue and I'd
like to share these things with my
project team as well to make sure that
they also don't wind up in situations
where they create communications
problems if that's all right with you
the stakeholders in my experience have
never resisted having you share the
information with the project team
because they really want everybody on
the team to to meet their needs in terms
of establishing trust so here's an
example of a start-stop keep that sin
filled out so the stakeholders saying
look start call my cell or email me and
iam Amy do both if you think you're
going to be late for a meeting because I
may be away from email and I'd rather
get a call or an SMS to my cell
no matter where I am so that I can let
other people in my organization who are
in the meeting know we may decide to
start later in which case they can stay
in their offices and not waste time or
um we may change our agenda and put you
later on because we have other things we
can cover if we're left waiting for
three or four or five or ten or fifteen
minutes for you to get there and I don't
know what's going on it's really a
problem and it ruins the productivity so
that's that's what I want you to do and
your team mates should be the same you
have a tendency time to interrupt me in
the middle of what I'm saying so please
don't ever do that again
don't interrupt me because it makes me
look less effective and it makes my
teammates look less effective and it
makes you learn how a less effective in
communicating if I'm trying to speak and
you break in I lose my chain of thought
and at the same time other people on my
team in yours are looking at me saying
she's pretty weak she doesn't have much
executive presence she's letting him
walk all over her so do not interrupt me
again
in fact we've got to figure out some
sort of a code so that you will know if
you're starting to do it and at that
point what I would say is I actually
have a tool for this I have a little
stone that says silence on it this is
absolutely true and I'll keep the
silence stone or give it to you whenever
we're in a conversation and if I ever
start to talk or if I even talk too long
you simply push the stone in my
direction
at that point I have to stop talking
until you know I didn't give any
permission to start it's actually a
great way to keep to keep a talkative
person on a tight leash if you need to
do that then in terms of the the third
the third of the start/stop key she
tells me that she really appreciates our
project status meetings this is
something that we do sometimes in person
but often with a Skype call and being up
to date on all of the things that are
going on is something that she really
likes and she wants to know if the
projects on schedule she also wants to
know whether there are obstacles that my
team is facing so that she can help us
deal with them she can champion us in
her organization now you may want to
think about how you would do something
like this with your own stakeholder the
the the way that I've done it here we're
picking one thing to start and when to
stop and one to keep because I found
that making a long laundry list of 15 or
16 things to change basic less likely
that you're gonna do any of them but
what I do with my stakeholder is say
let's make a long list of things that I
can can do it would change behavior in a
way that would better in your trust
let's say we come up with a list of a
dozen I say can we pick three your top
three for such stuff keep that we do in
the next 30 days I'll be mindful of the
others but what I really want to do is
nail this stuff down so that you see
solid progress and we can within you
know three three months latest we can
have this thing resolved and I hope that
you'll be completely satisfied in terms
of the way that we're working together
you can use 30 days in this day and age
you can use a week for each one or you
can decide that you're going to put more
than one thing in each cell I'm happy to
have you do any of those things you can
customize it to your wishes but the key
thing is to use this as a tool to help
your stakeholder tell you
she or he wants you to do and it's an
amazing tool to venture with the rest of
your team they can learn from your
experience and prevent them from doing
something in the future that they might
have done had they not had the learning
from your from your experience so in a
nutshell you can use a trust fighter at
the project start with any of your
stakeholders I would do this in my
initial meetings with my client and
certainly if we've got other people in
the client organization I do it with my
entire project team as well and with any
consultants that we have on the team so
that we know that we're aligned I do ask
stakeholders for examples of good
admitted performance and I'd encourage
you to do that as well
it'll be amazing how many good concrete
examples of good behavior and that
behavior you can accumulate over time
and share with your project team is a
rich database of things that work and
things that don't as I had mentioned get
your project team to do this trust
fighter and have them look for
differences in the top five across the
team this will actually help your team
to work more smoothly with each other
and also with you to get great team
building tool and what you definitely
want to do is communicate each of your
stakeholders top five priorities to your
team what you're going to wind up
happening in when you do that actually
is let's say you have five stakeholders
and they have different sorts of top
fives the team is going to have to wind
up paying attention to everything on the
spider but they're going to pay
attention with more emphasis with one
stakeholder on certain five things than
they will with another and in a very
strange way it helps the team across the
board to earn trust more rapidly and to
retrieve or rebuild trust after it's
been broken it's critically important
once you've done this thing to monitor
performance I think weekly is probably a
little too often but monthly is probably
you wouldn't want to do more than a
month and you'd certainly want to do it
major project milestones and I would
encourage
you doing with your stakeholders but
have the teammates do it with theirs and
also have the teammates do it with each
other so that they can figure out how
the team can work for more clearly now
when I say have this teammates used to
trust Spyder with their stakeholders
what you don't want is you and eleven
teammates separately going to Karissa
and asking her so make sure that there's
one point of intervention for the
meeting and you can have Karissa share
with you what each member of your team
has a problem with that's easy to do but
you don't want 12 separate meetings and
then again using the start-stop key it's
a very easy way for stakeholders to give
you specific concrete ideas on how you
can change your behavior to close trust
gaps and to build greater trust
I hate academic books that are long and
tedious and are filled with tools that
have never been tried and that are hard
to use I'm a project manager myself have
been been one for more years than I want
to count will gestation 78 when I was a
systems integrator and a project manager
and these tools really work in the real
world so at this point I'd like to open
it up for any questions and make sure
that we let you have a chance to
interact with us about the tool and also
any other general questions about SCPD
and by the way the appendix is there
will they get will they get a copy of
the document yes they will get a copy of
the entire document that's great so what
we'd like to do now is we have a number
of questions that I'm going to ask Tom
and then what we'll also do is as you
think of more questions during my
segment of the presentation we'll have
another Q&A session at the end so a
couple of questions that I've heard tom
one is it seems like a fairly high level
of trust needs to exist to even be able
to have this kind of a conversation with
some
how do you handle dealing with negative
stakeholders great question what I would
do first of all you I don't think you
need a high level of trust introduce a
tool I introduce it to people on first
meeting and say I want to earn your
trust this is a way to help us do it in
that case it can be kind of an
icebreaker and you can in that case you
say would you at least let me show it to
you and see if you'd be willing to do
the exercise with me and then you do the
exercise and if they say I'm not
interested in your knowing that you know
you've got a stakeholder who's going to
be secretive then maybe a problem let's
imagine you've got a stakeholder that
you're already in trouble trouble with
what I would do there is jump
immediately to diagnostic and and I
would say my gosh I'm really sorry
first if you take a moment to identify
what you think are the biggest prior
already areas for your top five using
this fighter tell me what those are and
then take a few moments and map my
performance on the one to five scale to
let me know how we've been doing across
the entire spider including integrity in
the center make sure that you do talk to
the stakeholder but the importance of
integrity and at the same time um you
should always carry with you your
current version of where you think you
are in terms of your own self-assessment
when you see what the stakeholder is
done I don't even know that I bring up
my self assessment at that point I
probably wouldn't I would note where the
where the sources are low I don't know
whether can I can I move the slides back
and forth okay so let's imagine that
you've the stakeholders really cranky
and I'm trying to let me get to that
here we go
there is it I want to stay cool no okay
sorry guys here we go that's that's what
we want let's imagine that you've given
a stakeholder the the the tool and this
is what he's done have a serious
conversation about the top five but if
you see that under humility that you're
scoring a one I would definitely work on
that as well as you get a get a very
comprehensive longer list of the things
that you need to change and I would very
gently ask whether the stakeholder would
be willing to go through the stuff
starts up keep analysis to make sure
that we have concrete things that you
can do to get better and if they agree
that is again if Medusa starts stuck
keep around the horn this is going to be
a much longer exercise where you're
going to be taking a lot of notes but it
is worth doing if you've got a
stakeholder who's angry and there's
another thing if they're they're angry
enough or enough conflict that they're
yelling at you or in active
confrontation we have something called a
dozen DS which we will be using in the
in the state in the stakeholder workshop
that I don't have with me today it's a
way to reduce the conflict so that you
can get to the point that you can
introduce the stakeholder tool did that
answer the question
yeah that was great thank you Tom so the
person who asked it if if in fact it
didn't answer it came back great so
another question we have here is how
would we practice sort of the silent
scenario in a virtual project
environment we can set some meeting
rules but it's really difficult when
project members are virtual can you talk
a little bit about techniques you might
use for virtual scenarios oh that's a
that's a great question because we have
that problem on our virtual team
meetings all the time
it's whatever do is establish at the
beginning of the project a a code that
everybody who's on the virtual meeting
can use if they want someone who is
tough talking to stop and take a breath
and what we've been doing on our project
is just the word stop and so the first
you know first one who says stop often
the person doesn't hear it and keeps on
talking but then what you do let's say
you have four people on the meeting at
once rambling along the one of you goes
stop the second goes stop and you keep
saying stop to where the person in
talking is having three teammates say
stop stop stop and and so if you don't
like the word stop because it's too
forceful you could take you can use the
word breathe or the word wait so that's
one way to do it if you're using in
addition to voice the way that we're
doing now if you have say you have a
Skype call and you can send each other
messages you can send the teammate who's
rambling on a text message on skype
saying please stop you're not getting
the client enough time to talk or
whatever it is or you can if it's a
pressure key member you could say stop
immediately to hear you know you're
you're joining us a client so those are
two ways sending a text message and also
vocally doing it applying peer pressure
and oh the last thing there is take the
person who's if somebody's sort of a
repeat offender on this I would
definitely take them into a session and
use the start/stop keep with them and
have them work through the way that they
can change their behavior in virtual
meetings I think it's well worth and
then you can check up you know after
each meeting as to how they're doing and
it's that's a hard behavior change for
somebody to make but they can if they're
given concrete guidance on how to do it
and reinforcement positive reinforcement
when they when you say cannot you only
interrupt it three times this meeting
and
when we talk to you along twice and
that's half as much as you normally do
you'll get people to change then well in
most cases you have some people who are
unchangeable but that's another issue
great actually that answered another
question Tom which is how do you
recommend dealing with people that want
to steal the show at every meeting so
you led right into that one we have
another great question here so how do
you do this with your team with whom
you've worked with for over ten years
and have a lot of history I think I
think it's fun as a so let's say you
have it it's either a team that's
working together really well with a lot
of history or it's a team that you've
got some conflict with a lot of history
and in either case bringing this into an
established team can be a great exercise
to help understand each other better for
the next project or the next you know
quarter or whatever you say hey we've
been together for a really long time
we've got some pretty important goals
either for the next phase of the project
or for the next time period let's go
through an exercise to see if we can
become more effective as a team in
building trust with each other and also
building trust with our stakeholders and
then you explain how it works and you
have people you know fill things out
separately and then compare around the
room and then have you have the team the
way the way this the way that we've done
this in the past
each team member would give the it's a
say for me if I had 10 team members each
of them would fill out a start-stop keep
for me so I'd have 10 and I could
compare them and if it's you know one
person who's complaining about something
and other people are saying keep that it
really works that's a different story
than if four or five out of the ten are
saying stop doing this right and so it's
a really good way to kind of a 360
around the team that's informal that's
not part of your whole performance
appraisal process and you can use it as
a way to
to have it just among the team so you
again you have each person identified
their top five share across the team so
that everybody realizes what the
differences are yeah each team member do
a start-stop keep on each of his or her
colleagues and that you can't do you
know in ten or fifteen minutes this is
something that you might ask them to do
over over a couple of days and then
submit them digitally so that they'll be
anonymous and then you put together the
little deck that has the start/stop key
each team member gets a little dick with
his or her action items so that's what I
do great so I'm going to give my team a
chance to continue to collect some
contact questions and we'll come back to
this in a few moments as Tom alluded to
there's a number of slides in the PDF
stack that Tom will not be discussing
today but we will provide those as part
of an appendix so you'll you'll get
those with the PDF can we flesh through
them on the way to your part yeah
absolutely we can do that give me two
seconds here so start here so you'll see
there's several slides here with some
behaviors that are attached yeah and
basically for each of the each of the
qualities on the spider these are things
that have been built up by my asking
lots of clients and stakeholders and
lots of project leaders so it hasn't
been done by a scientific survey with
thousands of respondents and all of that
but it's based on a lot of real-world
experience you can by the way add to
this as your clients and sponsors and
stakeholders come up with other things
about what they mean by empathy or
cooperation or whatever and you can add
spider legs I didn't mention that but
you always ask the client or the
stakeholder is another thing that's
really important earn your trust that we
don't have on this fighter so let's
if there's something yeah so you can
have a multi-legged spider don't
hesitate to improvise on this to
customize it for the needs of the
various stakeholders hey so we wanted to
give you some information about how you
can learn more from Tom so at the
Stanford center for professional
development we've been delivering
education to industry for over 40 years
so we have reasonable experience
creating these educational programs to
address the career lung learning needs
of professionals managers project
managers and executives and Industry we
at Stanford are pleased to be offering
the Stanford advanced project management
certificate program for over eleven
years with IP solutions and in
partnership with Professor ray Leavitt
we believe that the certificate is quite
a unique offering because it blends the
industry practical experience from
experts at IT solutions with the
Stanford theory and research that you
heard about from from Tom today
resulting in a truly rigorous and
advanced program what we try to do in
creating the program is offer courses
via very flexible delivery options so
that you can either come to Stanford's
campus in March June or September you
can take courses online via streaming
video at anytime 24/7 or through our
partners that IP solutions and those can
be delivered at your company work sites
for cohorts of 20 or more let me give
you a little bit of information about
the certificate program itself the
program was created for leaders and
managers who want to improve their
ability to convert strategy into action
through project program and portfolio
management and that of their
organizations and teams and we take a
truly organizational perspective in the
curriculum that focuses on operating in
a global context and improving
productivity and profitability you'll
see here that there are three required
courses with converting strategy and
inaction mastering the project portfolio
and leadership for strategic execution
the program requires that you complete
six courses and so you'll see there's a
number of electives that you can
choose from including the new course
that we'll be offering in June called
sold winning stakeholder commitments and
that that course is the one that Tom is
the academic director oven so you can
hear hear more about some of his tools
in that course so here we have the
calendar and you'll you'll see some
dates for the March and June on-campus
sessions and when the core and elective
courses are as well as some pricing
details there's also the early
registration discount if you sign up by
January 31st for March courses and May
1st for June courses where you can save
over two hundred and fifty dollars of
course and so now we'd like to just take
a moment to conduct a poll here if you
could we really appreciate your feedback
on this if you could just indicate your
level of interest in the FA p.m.
certificate program we'd really
appreciate it
I'll keep that open so we really truly
appreciate your feedback on this so
thank you and so with that I'd like to
come back and we'll do a few more
questions my team is able to gather some
additional questions here
well while you're looking at those if
any of you have taken a course called
leveraging customer relationships on
campus with with Katherine bar as one of
my teammates I want to let you know that
Katherine will be back for the new
course that we're working on as well as
lino green and we're going to bring some
other folks in as well so you're not
going to be putting up with cosmyk is
the only the only person there for the
whole time we'll have a talented
colleague from from IP solutions as well
it's gonna be fun great so here's here's
another good question time so what if
the stakeholder is a new stakeholder and
as a customer that we've never met how
can they assess you in the first place
now what you wouldn't if it's a brand
new stakeholder all that you want to do
in the first meeting is fine show them
your top five and asked them about their
top five priorities and then ask them
about the kind of behaviors from past
project managers or best people that
they dealt with that would be an example
of good practice or bad and then if it's
a first meeting I'd say look can we meet
again at a reasonable time frame it may
be in 30 days if you're gonna be working
fairly closely with that person or you
know 60 whatever whatever the number of
days is that you think appropriate or
you could ask the stakeholder I'd like
to meet with you again after we've been
working together awhile to see how I'm
doing in terms of earning your trust how
long should we I want you
we went links you when would be best to
schedule that meeting and that way the
stakeholder can say okay one in two
weeks or one in six weeks or one in a
month and you have automatically locked
in an agreement to get feedback on how
your
in terms of trust-building in that first
meeting I don't have to know anything
about you in in order to do the first
exercise great so another question here
so how do you filter out when a
stakeholder is communicating what they
think you want to hear rather than what
they really think so that you get good
feedback so one thing I do is to say can
you tell me more about why you picked
those five as your top five then let
them elaborate on that a little bit and
then you can say well if I gave you the
next five what would you what would you
pick so that you can get other
priorities I think that in terms of them
gaming the system there's always a risk
if you ask anybody to fill out any kind
of a questionnaire do any sort of a
thing that they may gain the system and
I think that the the two things that I'm
suggesting are certainly things that you
can do to try to get underneath what may
be going on I can't I can't think of
another other than to ask why if it's a
new stakeholder I wouldn't say gee it
looks like you're telling me you're
filling this out in a way that I want to
hear it that would be too direct so I
think just asking them why the first
fire is so important asking others that
would be important asking for behavior
on the entire the entire spider in terms
of what our good behaviors and what our
bad behaviors with respect to every item
on this spider make sure that you know
if they're telling you the truth about
what to do and what not to do you know
how to handle any of the legs and you
know how to handle integrity if in fact
you think they're leading you down a
path where they're telling you to do
things that you know are going to get
you in trouble with other stakeholders
what I would do then
is go to a stakeholder in that
organization that I trust and say help
me you know I I just I got some guidance
from one of your colleagues that seems
to be the opposite of what most clients
want and it's a culture in your
organization this way should we be
behaving this way or not and typically
if you've got somebody who's a difficult
person to work for in a client
organization the others will help you to
insulate yourself from there for her a
few proach it properly
great well so one final question so
everyone has an opinion so if you're
working on a team and you have say take
ten different stakeholders that have ten
opinions sometimes those opinions are
really conflicting about trust so do you
recommend consolidating these ideas down
into one model for everyone or or how
would you approach that well yes you
would you definitely want the team to
see each individual stakeholders from
top five because people are different
the problem of taking an average of all
the stakeholders if you don't average
you're going to get a very funny number
if you take the maximum of every
stakeholder you're going to get a
perfect circle around that around the
edge of the ring most likely in in in
fact the the team wants to try to
perform well on each one of these
variables but you want to particularly
emphasize the top five of a particular
stakeholder that's so you do want the
team to see everything but you want to
see the stakeholders one by one so that
they know that you would you would treat
Chrissa differently from Robert or Tom
or whoever and it's I hope I've answered
that that clearly having those things
available to the teammates and going
back to them say okay how are we doing
with this stakeholder did they seem
upset with us if so which what do you
think is going wrong when the trust
fighter in let's let's get somebody in
there who has the best relationship with
that stakeholder to take his or her
temperature and figure out what's going
on
great well thank you Tom I just want to
note that this was really valuable and I
happen to be thinking about using this
trust writer with my team so this is
great so yeah one last story um this has
been used by senior executives in very
large companies and project teams all
over it all so we used it with a pair of
co-founders who joined as I was a found
a company or not and they realized they
were so different that they decided not
to start the company then they both have
thanked me for it ever since
so sometimes do you agree not to work
together what do you have the choice not
to work together that's not usually the
case for project managers usually you
you have to do what you have to do but
anyway back to ERISA that's great that's
a great story so you know this concludes
today's webinar but I want to assure you
that there are still a number of
questions in the queue and and we'll be
sticking around to make sure all those
questions get answered this is a
reminder you can print the PDF of the
slides and you will have those appendix
items in there as well just by selecting
the print to PDF option in the lower
navigation bar and please remember to
look for an email that'll be coming from
Robert that will alert you when the
webinar is available online we'll get
that out to you as soon as we can and
thanks again and thanks again to Tom we
definitely appreciate the webinar and I
think Tom has one more confident yeah if
any of you have another spider leg you
know there's a quality you think is
really really important we would love to
find that out okay because that we've
been using this around the world it's
been fairly stable but I am in these
changing times we may need to add some
dimensions okay thanks great thanks Tom
you